шеннон та і владимир гри над нові
члени уряду
ш борги учасник цього засідання
цю скільки за раз постав цієї
політичній пропозиції що дорі
формування середнього squid іншого
українська школа я хотіла туди значить
рахунок над метою реформи та націю
пропозицію працювала навіть широкому колу
людей і я хотів розгойдати няшностей
бо вся робота вимагала хлопчик
цирк i wanna be цирк алана в законі
процвітає ж проголосований ей померлому
читаю нею в парламенті али
для нас дуже важливо політично воля з
диво троянду мене пріоритетності якщо ти
ціль і ряд виявляє таку політичну
волю там ми прийняли рішення саме всю
політичне пропозицію затвердіє і так
вже розпорядженням кабінету міністрів
україни сьогодні і дуже багато в dc
дискусій про школу і я хочу забута ти
хто тих хто за ту голу школу you
їй і стануть якою є сьогодні the
batch а ось вище 10 2 сотки в батьки
15 адже сотні вчителів висимо 500 ки в
директорії в шпиль прийому повз нього на
ринку брати ту ж складну ситуацію
уколи у нас є факти дж але процес
даного на сьогодні всього 3 і більше 16
мільйонів осі або з льону тобто
зайнятості 5 сплячий бо сотки
приціл у середній школі навіть підкоряється
профілізації мовчання та виявлення
індивідуальні фільми 100 дітей нас
сьогодні такі витрати на дітей старшої
моїй школі жив і вся підлога і блювати і
свої знання за прибраними оком і одразу
мило що все спирт зовсім лову
від частоти з такою повстання до відома
каже 76 і сотки хоче мін середній
глядач ікони намагаюся діною
критичній ситуації знову котити
середнього світу то чоловік нас тусується
всіх його за скронь і за конституцію я
хочу коротко to raise у мегі олаф ета
крим на вигляд повернися результативно
іржання у чехова ним з вузькою папір
у ринку проси wetsuit неси ревнувати про
стуку дай окисною середні про святі
втомилися місії не залізними категоріями та
зате реліз місця святі методик і
викладання низький соціальний статус
супротивники ось святі ми задурили
матеріально-технічне забезпечення
бюрократична система управління святу
завис потрібно знаємо про sie alle на наше
завдання сьогодні клімат і в мої будні там
вже в школа c то інститутська команд і в
цієї самої but не викликало сьогодні ми
можемо відмовитися я крем і технологіям і
і якими професіями будуть волги ти гей
ти чи сьогодні in спілкуються у підкові
школі через 20 роки
ми точно знаємо що він і житиме і
зшити без мінного з вуст якщо нижче ми
сьогодні там я всю себе , що потрапив промити
у вони їм мої статті випускницю приватні
нові українські школи я до нас правді
живе у новому етапі України
демократичні україни європейської
україні та до мої статті та багато кіно you
вона ресурсний українець такий cl через
вас пригостити грім один їм вигляд побачити
nike патріот та та багато turbo інновацій
на ми сьогодні по 1
кожному ж виявляється у так званих
ключових компетентностей праведниці сем
і зростання with ease with у яги в
європейському союзі
вже давно було етюди sku цю продажів
швидко ти рокки і балян ти про мережу
компетентності ванни з литого не в
законі право свиту ось цей путіна не на
дві колонки дурень ще б потайки потенції
всі одразу розбиті міфи вивчимо пари ти
адже школи знав-то школи cum
плямистий ті призначають школі в школі
компетентності пропадуть знання знання
азартно копит обличчя з драматичні шви та
судити вже не тикати школах у мене
motley crue табір інтернет дуже багато
різьблених ресурсі є риба на вч цієї
акції знання бак арештовані
я трохи охолонути та kuwait та отрута види якщо
ти добро від зла та ясної ці знання кита
by patrick не для ви вирішення
індивідуальні ж ті ви випробуваєте і
шифрів і сильного ви ікла так ось у
компетентності включають я трос на піку
мене та навички як дзвонимо їдкі навички та
так самий ніс і ті сині тіні сну
платформа через якути буду їж ставлю
немає лісових ситуацій і можеш приховані що
переосмислив цією інформацією я буду без
рудовий придушити
від е або колонка з спадання мобам і
математичка грабко грамот низькому б
плямистий природний чиїх науках
технологіях інформативно цифру баком
patek з метою нашої школи
елітний хвостик на спалення тандир вигляд
добрі та їжі станція до кінця ціни
формується в компетентних teal ошень я
сумую або приватні черкаси
теоретичних знань через
іди ти зустрічає дуже швидко мотивацію та
interest in a адже вони відійшли
а ось право колонка вміння jackets
продовжити від соціального грому не пекельний
computed насипу приймаю весь ефір та
фінансово грамотний загальна культурно
грама
екологічно грамотність і здорово жити
цінам рибалок і шкода абсолютно било
прямо в українське творіння про святих
самій з
секунд патент на знімають люди але труби
ти успішну всім u20 першому столики і
накрили дурити підтвердження та
кореляція з зажадав міс народного
ринку профі
я київ про значення недавнього недавнього
світловим економічним форумом поясом та
цілити дзеркальним
і на жаль мовляв робота доці я до шкіл можна
цикл забезпечать і в результаті у гори ми
будемо крим али на і пищить 9 таких
головних складів та нові вниз усвяти
і ми вже пожинаємо проти ти натанівна
ньому державну стандарту модифіковано
в 4 педагогіка партнерства принцип
дитину центризм у нас брудний процес
вишивання щоб злитися на тінистих
нова структура школи
реально автономія жки у правій брилі
фінансово не з жахливою про свині середа
вашої інклюзивного свято я хочу суп або
ти зовсім таких кісткових і над ними я
кит дуже важливий для нас у принципі як
для уряду там уже рахунок із вона знизу блювати
про світячи наші експерти ми прекрасному
зуміємо я яким су доні micron і закони я
кіт прекрасний стандарти ми написав і
і отрута була б me а ну вилазь місця почту
я все не буду ось і вований його вчителя але
важливим зливам кваліфікацією і до
думати не старими іранськими
і штампам і про авторитарно по дорозі q
і вище трансляції знання кігі ти майк
вікторії ти на іспит а у нас не буде
реального формування за їх компетентністю
там так важливі у що потрібен ікіка gunvor
біля порога для нас важливим, що ми прошиємо
of 4
загальна квітник на чайних закладіть на
доватора їх не розряди в порядку я вона
чула його штук з російської зарубаною на
плато з нас тут на урок я мовляв
адже сотки
viano свожу його що ми в законі про
свиту за клав їх онуку системи
підвищення кваліфікації вчителів та модний
вулим добровільної сертифікації та краху
вимиємо парі девід авторитарні дорогою
до педагогіки партнерства верхових про що
вона вчить їх і істота страшною
цінностям демократії паван це хитрощі
шкірні людина ціла купа надихається з
молочку і так сама cbd та й мет
і ви ковтання і ось тут я душі важливі в
тільки на яку я купила згорнутий і
і речей дискусії у нас крутиться на
колу 2 націю того руку мовчання сізо
існує наших дітей клімат ще один ріку
школі так ось колега я кашинський шпулей
акуми майн за раз той зміни по три дні
два тому і рид і поспішай не відривалися
інакше вони
моїх значення владне для школи ком
патент вниз ноги
тому що значним менше початкового
ділянці позики я для вчителя та з педагога
всезнайки трекеру сказати і матеріали
gedit і моїх простого пан я то ти або
творить і ніжна справді організувати та
компа танкісти на бронікон егіди відсоток
грубо створити проекти захищає владу
ми за званням у метнувши хитатися продовжити
я виріжу ось із щільнішої проблеми
аргументу вати свою боргу критичному якщо
ти і твої та шукай технології на джаміль
ці виробляють абсолютно до
лише аулія впасти і результату яких роб
осіб з дітей наталі успішними і я
виросту для говорю про яч-чи 10
сотки в tedx 0 найуспішніших дітей кіпр і
махають у нас з літніх олімпіадах
шеннон її колеги ми можемо з будувати
suspense черевики через істоту свічку на
покладав там уже і душ ділянки ланцюга від
10 адже сотки поки і дарувати краю ну а
нас правді економіка та стають qualify
корони ми кадром і
сама раз буду ви і люди я тюзі селом у
з успіхи тому нам твій багатих та чоловіки
диски з але якщо ти для них і ви душі
. відкривалася синапса не хоче кого
школа 4 рок та базово 5 руки та star намети
особисто профіль на середній школі та кому ж
мати 2
перебування з академічно елітні
гід і радіє доступ овочі овочі
початковий заклад обидва профі sin x
перебування центрів та сильний обличчя чіпів
і сильний калач де можна буряти і
зональні середню святими з дубу ватою
так вже свою персону бітну кваліфікацію
я хочу пити крісло ти що сьогодні долина
троянд в цей пропис ну технічні його
свити
силоміць підв'язані з метою реформи і
школи та
на території Європи сьогодні у дена 4
чко з пари очей у трьох околицях росії та
білорусії та україні d c крадених
прив'язаний це пупу воїн з другого знання
ви та школи 20 столики як сьогодні
перебували нас правдиві глибокі щури
шину миколи я хотіла всі закони фізики
на 2 важіль тиж важливих для урядів з
справедливо фінансово не за радість
правоту його доступу доз квіти з цифрою 3
7 форми для централізації. адже буває
сезара і бро зірки бакарі санья
кішки в бочки чин іншої їжі нарікань з
сторони бочки і шелдон і крутий російською
ви короста її з них кішки і зла краще
не я з їхньої кішки ми сьогодні з вами ми
можемо і сказати про генеральне тіньові
бюджет шпиль із лога не реальний бюджет
і думав у законі просить піти наша
пропозиція так вже й тут ми порибалив і
що все кішкою окинути новосвіт у моїх
ніби просторі
і шкіряний захоплення святим арі поки за те
що вино кримів через суд gantz державу
бюджету шо хвилин remo вниз зліва бюджету
і шопінг цей уривок з бочки і як циви
кури 100 вається для забезпечення свободи
вибору ми
крупу ну йому за круглого за провід цієї
принцип жорсткіше ходить забитими
особливі лузини активний і актуальний для
дітей інвалідністю
про корені школи визнає емоцій проектор
випадковий за раз скарбу і ми тут йду волі
багата кішки я хочу за поважати і що при
ремонтах завзятих скилл
ми нам коню йому право жив чи створи не
доступу для цехін владні дітей з
інвалідністю сьогодні Тетяна стужі
важливий проект інклюзивного squid та
дурниці так вже впікають і з марина
анатоліївна парусину ми зачіпка чий тому
що з аптеці яйця і ти стоїш і їжі
тобто по ширині oleg все ваш вибір для
нас і для уряду pvp шипи рибалив і су
спеціалізації будь-якої субвенції на трюк
кохання знову кошторис на 2017 рік і ось у
йому порядок і вокаліст onew
суджа сни us with nice app це вище
сьогодні ми моєму інформації не технології
нібито літній пам'ять шлик до святих і
для нас я грунт кабінету міністрів стоїть
шоу на завдання київ полетиш нею під
пропозиції новий вид критим
онлайн-платформа доступу для чат або
для дітей то нових мотор ялик та методах
компонент не знову на вч вони ще вижив
його ми миємо сьогодні дітей на
окупованих інший підконтрольних
територіях
ми по ви не вирвати зі своїх дітей до
для туші он і продовжив і навчання в
україні став і храм океаном та україни
ці шляхи будуть прийняті грува тайці
території і ми не можемо з роботою замку
криза раз організації сам це як
дистанційних курсів на крити її
платформі дивани зможете станційно
свобода українського світу бог же 2
випуск мільйони видав якщо їй систем його
світи графіт супроводі реформи я
хочу заспокойся всіх наших опонентів
яких говорити що вся реформа є добре
для реалізації вова на ту саму дорогу
кішку та
околиці 1 гіршого нога та ти шо нас
правді найвищого я правда не ресурс їм
ви стоїте ацетоїн висоті до вкладу на
блюдце та капітал країни подруга
мити реформу тут їм на випадок
куща плову ми в жирній або виступала на
2017 recon і закладає вийшли не
зарплати вчителям
червона про церкву піци це відповідь 2 над цією
річки кагенек ipad рибу я в сьогоднішній
стінах податкова у чотири з половиною
мільярдів рибою зіграно цей ерік за
graphical супроводі реформи body as
u 2 тис за чітери 29 30 початковому уроці
я люблю що ціна помічаємо apus тупого та
супровід реформи ми могли пили за
право животи шви дші
all ми згортаємо україни давид буває
заздрість до виду
і ми з чоловіком баготу in виступати в
нашу оборону запис я хочу ситуація
пофарбований у здасться ми зможемо упряж
відрахування
темп цілей реформи, а ви для нас важливі
ваш суп реформа була підготовлена ​​все
означали масове підвищення кваліфікації
у 4 цілих почали новинок жадібніше
матеріали ціну спочатку вид купити
низовинним магазинів шалені за прапори з і
фазери форми в політичний пропускайте
розшуку не і джефрі євтих основних
заходу яким і до вас не тут немає і я не
буду зараза шлюбом години на знайди ви
зрозумілості аллаган і на випадково
конкретніше готова vip повести на , як
восени в ці результати сьогодні прем'єру
своїм від сукном умови сказавши що з куди
виду бра жалість на все сплачено найкращий
вид того якими е.я. я до еге
успішність наших гіней та процедур що
ваня них на ринку практики гри
норми права кольору показують свої
результати гід долану
той там і великий продукт нової
української школи та починається з 17 19
початкового руку
будемо від і u20 білизни там втратить розуму та
шо роботи в сьогоднішній витя я всього дні
адже за we gotta націй викл і кайтінг
техніки вже навчаються у школі ми
розгойдалася всю роботу також там вже ми
пробули поперся персик рок і вже
дорослими він вул і не програми чітко
ви та школи на платформі ця ера
виставлено вже за node40 відео на
допомогу це ямка про нові програми
поспішали історій на закладення україни
зрубали хрестоматії для літературного
чухання для початку ви зі школи
stacks тільця приватних 3 дж їх batman та
перепаювання
candida і читає скиглії тексти - у вас
докази
образи читають текст і прожити від і своїх
співучасників
я кеги їм влади і шо вижив і ось для
нас
я хотіла на всіх я до політики рядок за
клік від і до розуміння нашу і вид
побачилися і я всі ми будемо він звали
катинг
останню реформи тощо. як звалася і
на світ віра блендер і форми і колір senor
його рідні рублі не реформи в 100 ієн
на кубик циpку шульги не конкурент нас
про потужності наші та усвяти
заощадження тенденції зниження нехай їх
вийти!
apple знайди сухих людей зниження
яскравості людського капіталу
їх витрата наукова технічна потенціалу
держави з
я намазую себе куртку щоб а ти
зараз на вигляд виведено за харчування all in
хотіла б сказати шо дзеркалі точно
пропозиція передпо чай так вже
комунікативний план tejo та реформи чуму
адже для нас had або шви ви звідки pets
ери форма на 10 витя і ми не знаємо sti
здається то сетевики можеш змінити з
парламенті і побачивши ми по ви не зруби ти
за 1 з tubes успішності стала владно
контейнери форми та пишу ми за початку їм
та запуск йому нову українську школу 18
19 початковому уроку з teens успішно
змушувала тури форму продовжу вати всіх
політики та у ряди який стрибати якщо нас
там у я за кликаю всіх своїх колег
сьогодні Петро ім а ти ж видно
розпорядження проспала не концепції
реалізації державні політики хочу
сказати про серце виду громадянам законі
право свиту москва на нековому та учню
йому у парламенті
а в тебе книжечка мета забарвлення їй
комунікативної документики та людської
можуть для всіх версій
грому диска вас успіхи для шкіри
до речі здається тен яко maisto то
українська школа пояснюючи все становище
ці вид дзеркала не в законі право скиту
я на когось чекає розмістив на презентацію
явних штани з моменту з'їхали б я
потрапити під собою в 4к я її теж уже
теж кожному
раз повідає 1 військового шкіл я пас
повернувся там він уже так ми не
playstation саду ж такі гори з приводу
якову або вокальна худоба рахунок ось все
мови пройти сказала нелі буквально
повішення конкурент нас промежини
середнього спиці в Україні з колишньою
тенденції дуб та підтримання
я кістки всіх воєн його світлим зниження до
стилю скол капіталу конкурентність
strata malkova технічного потенціалу
поттером по всіх трьох різаках ми моєму
абсолютну реальність сентрі бульбашками
маймон і от і впровадженці очевидно що це
треба зміню в чому я не заводом сієни
дзвону з термінами 29 рік і обожнюєш у це
дуже туш будинком я на початку сказав про
те, що людям на бридлаву трохи допустити
напружися реформи і не розумієте
ще ми починаємо ніж ми закінчимо мою
думаючому мета цикл про вонджу ними на
моєму but is меншими сама особиста
думка і не можна за фінансував про дату
богині не я полегшу ми могли б пара
хват йому c
сестра ти гарна
таких витрати хорошого ми вимили за нас
тут на країну посилання будуть читати бірж
і не поспішаємо на присту йому через розум і
пропозиція за допомогою ми з карнавали
рядки монет принципі
велике ось і всі ми розбиваємо такі
фази навчальний термін єдиний ще де ти
у віковому у просто remains роботи краще
можливості коротше компетенції фарби
можна вас все тугіше і тугіше
[музика]
мої важливого значить я освітили ставлю
сюди тривоги крові у нас було з
широкої воронеж ненаситної конференції та
ми нас проблема йому душі після ти дні
безрукою для мене особливі стоячи для
міністра клав його що 90 сотки 4
його з виглядом мрію школу треба заміню
вати і до лівану не може чути таку
як я відразу милую що їй operations as
кути його в годину тени us within the пішов
треба висоти шоу свято дістати
консервативно система он і у свідомі
що для того, що перед їжею школи
complete and nice ми треба засовувати та
ноги методики nafanya алея вірю в
українського враховуючи перуку на наш
рабин який шум етапі крима його
українців у читали його соціальний
статус і до мого чоловіка його стеш єршей
для підвищення кваліфікації
ми всі зможемо труби ти а що до графіка
у право дженнер та форми міністерства
святим а їжте два варіанти по танку
супроводу реформи за цією ціною shit
синап це не я на цих етапах з кількома
кішки нам треба їм з вати в сури форму
то в такому і буду за право джиною 12
річка nafanya і я крем джимом б моєму
інвестувати ви дальняк та інші учні
там вже й колими вона в ньому кількома
оддейн клас наприклад перший
ti1 ціна колимугу ну млинець і перший і
п'ятий можна запустити і підкову школу
і базову 1 годину
ільшат синаїт що ми ловли м 1 5 і 10
тату dicere inhibit від цього ми і
готується пропан його ти всі моделі
супроводу та спину вийшов і вода
проти тайці
графік реформи з і поряд вже готові
виставити в області шан про мікросвіт мені
страшно у Миколи
нам блогу добрий петром цей проект
розпорядження річки еск валяються концепції
база вмираючих жабі та киданням законі
про почет які в парламенті вже в
великому вчить вони і у хваленого алла і
дияволи до дискусії подавець як харчування
розмістив в принципі всі виходять ось
ці але центризм тенісний пік hiit
української ідентичності повно будинкові
всі передачі на алі від porsche опозиції
ассасин 500 темного світу вид ВВП
традиція будай проти ти друга позиція
і як же випливаючи з місць вояка на
битися за нас на 12 особистого свята та
обдурити мали портфель ником.
річі та коди тютюнових мотив десятому роті
зрубує це сіквеле тату не побоявся
дурник езра б ось 12 і вбивши обов'язково
рахунок ядрі котушки та її свити щіток і
досить чарівність долоні в ніс виду
ще так і не просив у нас zara
знімає пошукові дужки але і з вигляду
стежку верта ти 2 над старичку алло я
простяг нам треба ризику збив ось і
престижність проти читера там ще два
на старичка передача і новий знову йду я
картин свити батька реакції 1c і ви ще й
sweet або підготовка вчителя та під
вічно противника також вимагай
підставі нових гармати і битва видно хліб
у 2029 річки домофону в секції дискусіях
соціального рибу протягнемо всім уроки і
df 20 очей великий фанат stay close
двадцять п'ятому уроці, а за провалюємо у
Юри форму 2018 руку від села пташка під
ним випустяться
це це вілли касу парочка буде в
сімнадцятому уроки по виніс ось це закон
про свиту я красну дівчину пластирі книга
нормально випливає я хрещена виду ряду
будинків сигнал фінансові петренко при
нами та базові етапі в ті та концепції
нової української школи то я думаю
число непрофільних та близько відбудеться
буде початок з правді візьми його і
реформи
бій снаряд всіх вас with sarah діапазону
вона ключ його на її реформи вітрову
буде чоловік наривати і дашкіна свято і
вищого світла і підпалити колись і так
далі і цитатами. заявку ще потягнуть
адже це будете по липчані вона завжди
the dead
я прем'єр-міністр нарис вид крісло ти
повністю абсолютну профільність та біт
ринку а світи в Україні в тому числі і
фінанси і наша ініціатива Петро шукає і
заробітну плату в 4 до 5 4 тонких вид
факту 16 роду шик рок стороні розумів
фінансові мотивації лінована
складності роботи українців у чотири
типу часто сваритись і будемо від усіх
турбот основа та обожнюючого yagis на свято
я кисні компетенції days нам реальним
правимо інакше можу там тартаком
виростила дірки розрізав і продав і а я
хотів би чим ми і малі на ваті і
ніж ебола та канкуро і щоб могла томати
пари дві позиції і він і кадр ось їх
рисаки об'єктивно сьогодні за рішенням
щонайменше тоді в чому і я почу довжину
проблемі ось з 12 особисту свиту
але вже я ще в школі вчився на мою
серцю символ 12/19 і тоді ми
шарахаємося з боку в бік одні
здаються 12 інші теж 22
не каже ці трубки інших трохи
а люди жодного разу не відомо, що люди
думають так ще
біг шоу mazda mazda ніби я ризикнув
свиту засунути струпів скорочуєш
забралась я з уз місцях тут покладеш
alive шо ми скажемо про те що за 12
ромці геть і реальної цього тримай
більший офісний компетентний і
будуть конкурентним і зможе
фарбуватися паралізувати я думаю та батьки
edit ну чого ви мчать з розумінням
теж у принципі у всіх даної
батарейки
закінчу 9 класі куди ти закінчив 11
класі в куди і ти кому ти куди це
почати з серцевим батальйон а ось такий
системи до помори у профілізації ви
значущості у нас не мій легший ось те й
залишиться килимки показував windows
можна весь зарин ту від і педро туго ти я
думаю що може бути сприйнята
українською зі списком проводячи нами
батька ми врахуємо і так далі
змаганні 5 простих освіти інститут
there's no mori монетами тоді фінальний
Володимир Борисович на жаль і цинком чутно
каже одна і важливі лише оцет піци
відразу мило за радіти і 12 рік ніж у
кулі ховайся он виправлені розумний і
розстебнув і просто зми зі свитою на два
на три дрова на для нас zara склав його
ціну результати тобі та нові школи для
дитину але віддано бартер для неї одні
відрубаєш що я хочу за поважати і зв'язку
що у нас буде три вічно старші
профіль на школа ми зможемо про бакалавра з
дугу вати за цілу миску та спеціально
зграйні за 4 а сатри ярок і за фатальний
долі ну модулем наша не старша і
профільні школи я ківі збувається
сьогодні
на території європейських країв там
унція душа перезріла і рішення якен і
обсі дну обов'язково за право java ти в
нашій системі квіти
таку допомогу люблю вас
дику я хотів би одну
нас правді за увагу забуті я навіть витають
ще за кута на активне прагнення
михайлівні
потрібно боліт працюють вже давно я я по
тому, хто збив праворуч, підносить свято
де ми успішно в повний ще плінтуса у
нас знайти кизильське студенти з
африканських коринтян і хоче їх ти
я поважаючий та мій той же також і del на
перевірку від очевидного ти
школи знань і прохід дає концепція я
поважають ну школі ми всі втрати за
собою комунікації зі святим і
Розумити цю святу в моєму розумі немає
fps на зимовому ви і 1000 називається
парадні що дисципліни і ви вчитатись у
в тому ще ми можемо від нього ось і великі
плюси та з'явилася можна
кільки в школі знання тому просто вид
ходять і віце концепцією.
пояс не ось ще такі sweet навколо
що поважає потрібно ту ж вежу і c1 і
концептуально за повагу до моменту
серії концепції я я ліберального
свитої у нас цеглини ясна можна буде
реальний старий і духи у чому я хотів би
погоду з прем'єр-міністром ми реально
надходило паба хочемо доки знаків впадаємо
вона його не
карина 3 поради я всі ми будемо гострого
живота і форму приблизно за графіком
методи в будинку залишково
і все нан ще Томас. за графіком
я птиж акуратно по меркулів ще можна
заробити ще в орто забуті
але від цих моментів щодо там фінансове
забезпечення нам чудово відразу мило ще
просто 5 ниткам зарплати ціни роботи в
принципі це може бути пішок рок-червона
конкуренції ми школами ціни вийти ось
титри моменти я хотів би за шанувати і
вищому особисто вітаю
дуже дякую була зміна чи віруєш лінії
пагорба хоча б править від of залі нову
концепцію
я хотів би сказати що ми можемо дізнатися
ти рішення і ким чен нам про фінансово
ти про скоро ти реформ сьогодні нас
зажадають великої шкоди купити сьогодні
середня почет з самих сільських школах
там до провалюються опорної школу там
газу промазується початкова школа як
приємно та опорної шкіл і мети буває з
реформою децентралізації переможних
територіальної громади
давайте самий там використовувати і
мета процес я думаю що на кіль киса
бідних територіальних громад за 1 т
формується шкільні простих можна знаєте
кішки із забезпечувати зон з і менше
яскраві сипіти ручники початкова школа і по
опорним базовим шкіл розумники будете
відкриватися бідних тріальних роман
опитують сумному нашу сільську
безсі вайс річка
ну нажаль а в трохи менше ливання
почти зовні на прихід у місця таким
таким чином ми будемо of rock it is заново на
плівку початківців проводжу цю реформу
телескопі цілості а надходило праворуч
животи та й надалі
мара фіг нібито гладка
канони Володимир Борисович хвилю не
кулагін
я б ліллем хана вам вироби ви я
практик інноватор і з піцу міг вашого
жити а практичної і сили ви in ватин і
ідеальності на перспективу
друга я хотів би сказати ще не з вини
піднятий престиж у 4 та мотивації тут-то
оплати проти це дуже важливо
знову те, що сказав понтон клімкін Петро
йому ютубу всі природні че і дисципліни
з вини базу ватої себе на школі прапор і
на німецький виправданої технології та кум
навик арештована 17 тост докази та unoa
правдою і сьогодні не почну європи та курчати
винуту природний чек
консерватизм світла
травня зал прозвітай аксіомою у все шукаємо і
з вини ми вивезли його ти їду рішення про
глиммер борисич пункті 15 17 минулого
хват і за стару будівлю міністерства
економіки яку 517 темряві 517
за це я тут не може болото пишу на
моєму шляху в кіно досі не школи результату
вала був бідно грамотах у нас е
концепція нової української школи
китя школа мої but i проте в базу та ксс
steam у вас краєвиди
чого get не дають реальні грамоти чума
like the muse або з овочів ніж місці що
в
балика разом ну я думаю пір цьому теж
важливі але щоб мета стандарту по всій
україні заправок нас на булочку тут
підхід усієї школи у нас кращий від дітей
школу нас є я школа є стандарт ми
до нього моїм прогнутий і не воїн густуватий
і
і дамаг тис однак і однак у їх чоловіки
ласти
зрозуміло рахунок все можна влади туризму
будуть у користі диск раніше ти з'їжджати
процес али можливості
нової української школи моїх but однак
видно все депо де ти спілкувалася?
читальні на іншого і так далі це дуже
його щоб зелімхан за вашої шкіри
щоб у миколаєві не а ти за добрі
слова як ринку через повагу та провину
що я хотіла підфарбувати особи можуть
важливого для всіх колимага злодієм у тата
адже рахіт школи знання вийду школи
компетентно відбудеться не означає, що
наші деталі будуть у читай ти любиш її
на за ним о чі інформації технології
ніж математику краще за чиєю доброю
природні чиєю наукою і назад не
завищується важливого в крові у цієї крим
правильно ядро ​​знання крем працювати
алана сидить і маленький навчіться
скрипковому якщо ти і в мід і викури 100
виведення цих знань для практичних і
prophecy
індивідуальних і профі сильних у ви
ікла син у нас ієї бичі проблеми і
там у я хотіла б зважити і що ось я
ситий вже добрий видно на такому прохолоді
можна читати вона жвавий
а можна читати з розумінням від усім-усім
у
ігро особливі варис думками школу
edit через підготовку шпану порцію
знань зі школи і я q і дикую ти точно
травня шпет грунті будь я їсти цю
проблему краще за професі ну roses
класний над зі стіни з натще за
стасу вати
інформацію для того, щоб розв'язати ці
проблеми там у
я одягаюсь що
ось так її умовляння не для настою сапу
руку і чоловіки вас і
за право дати туру форму шеф краще con
su ледово але розум
навіть я твою душу чесно робота 15-ти
почесних ми всі розуміємо червоним.
головне що одразу їм куди it і iced раба
рубль і без шику світі кого ти бути
каммі скотт підколоти тілом і буквально
ось якщо ти виступав і прибираєш і брат і
ніби з разок карнавалі свої ідеї ще
все було на 6 віртуально сказав саме
ніби
народна реформа з моя ніби реформа з
встигнути вид-во чого жодного разу не знайдуть ще
через всю реформу через знання ми будемо
над її usb саду ж важливо
ту ж гена ми за вас там дизайну
закладаємо такі фундаментальні промови та
до та будемо ця ціна bid проведені було за
розвиток джейн і десь светр q я буду
поверху на службу яке буду соціальною
політики і так далі і так далі
такі бази вероніка наш енергетична
стратегія всі базові промови кіно
закладають дають вигляд ви ж на
що дефіцит procs я сказав спочатку на
шиї
нашого засідання та дефіцит з успішним ой
будні повз нього дати великим би але ми про
по моїм чим було до слух це їзда людей
і рука тис дол
готелі цілий я про помою підлогу ти